we're looking in this chapter at the
Presbyterians and quite a bit of what
we're covering here ought to be familiar
to you from previous chapters where
reform movements matter of fact part of
what this chapters about is the other
reform what happened to them where did
they go to the only ones that actually
turn out to to have one of the presents
these days turn out to be the duct
reform the rest of them got absorbed
into the Presbyterians boring to the
Congregationalists and what was talked
about why in a few moments but to say
that their reform or Calvinist totally
awful lot about their embassies about
what it is that that's distinctive to
this this tradition so this will be a
little bit of review key things that you
remember about the Calvinist tradition
or like some of the terms or ideas or
distinctive very good so you know the
protestant reformation is about sola
scriptura Bible alone but these guys
took it a bit further you know one
Luther would say it's ok to have a mass
more or less the way it was Calvin would
say look unless it's in the Bible forget
you gotta get rid of it it's it's
anti-christian so that's one really key
f1 really key distinctive what else yeah
yeah this notion that from all time God
has chosen
who's going to heaven and who's doing
the hell was going to be saved who's
going to be damned and that there's
really nothing you can do about it
some some of the advocates of
predestination went so far as to say
you really don't have free will at least
when it comes to matters of salvation in
any important respect you do have free
will of assets like you've got shooters
whether you eat a salad or in a state
but you know whether you're going to
live a godly life or a worldly life they
would say that that's not the person and
then there were some other things that
went along with that like the limited
atonement Christ didn't die for
everybody just the people who were saved
what else is really important do you
think for for Presbyterians and for for
the perform in general yeah yeah that's
part of why predestination to celebrate
because well then you're right because
because original sin is why the Damned
are going to help but for them that's
kind of rolled into there your right to
it in you know thinking Calvin went back
to Augustine Augustine really emphasized
original sin so these guys grow going
back to Calvin are going to emphasize
that as well but what else think about
the term Presbyterian how do we use that
before not to talk about a denomination
but to talk about something else yeah
yeah so you have these elders and these
elders are the ones who really exercise
authority within the church it's not
just the minister or creature you have
these elders and how do they actually
find you others they choose them and
they're the ones who are involved with
church discipline they're the ones who
decide for example who gets to go to
communion who doesn't when the Puritans
we looked at that may they would
actually decide who can be a full member
of the church so these these uh this
means of organizations is very important
Calvin thought that this was
this is biblical this is the main way
that their electrician community
organized itself so your book talks
about a couple people in Scotland why
why is Scotland so forth until you know
sometimes find John not schools or
colleges because it's a very important
person for the Presbyterian denomination
and movement he's the guy who sort of
brains Calvin to Scotland and if you
know if you look at a map these days
Scotland doesn't look that far away from
Geneva just think about what it was like
back then you know Calvin and the
Calvinists were down in Switzerland and
France was pretty hostile to them being
livid go out of the way of the Anglican
reformation so there were some Puritans
in England this guy John Knox goes all
the way down and comes all the way back
up Scotland is so far north that you
know you guys all go about on the
Northern sodding in summer how it almost
doesn't set in some places Scotland was
like that that's how far north we're
talking about and travel was difficult
back then so this is a pretty important
thing yeah it says he brings he brings
Calvin's ideas and then Geneva's ideals
to what they're calling something like a
Celtic backwater torn apart by warring
clans and Presbyterianism Calvinism
becomes something really important for
Scottish I'm never really sure whether
you supposed to say Scottish or Scotch
football again I know there's some rule
for what you use
the other or Scott's - you can say but
this becomes really central the the
Scots who leave the Catholic Church and
that's most of them becoming
Presbyterians
yeah and Scotland and England has
long-term antagonism as well so this
fits in with the political rift between
Scotland and England - so this this
notion of covenant that we find in the
Presbyterian reform the movement becomes
very important for their political life
all of those substrates to pervade the
culture now your book talks about
organizing you know Presbyterian polity
that means forming a Presbyterian Church
something official something that would
be long lasting yeah why are we
interested in all this Scot stuff if
we're talking about religion in America
it's interesting right Scottish people
are curious and they have a funny accent
Scotland by the way nowadays is very
cosmopolitan
go there once you get far enough the
hinterland why are we so interested in
this religion and America yeah a lot of
people came from Scotland came to
America and brought with them their
traditions exactly the immigration is
how everybody got there including the
Native Americans as we talked about and
there's the Scots and then there's
what's called the scots-irish didn't you
have scots-irish ancestry you ever
wondered about what was that mean those
are the Northern Irish the people who
were brought originally from Scotland to
be sort of you know the vanguard of the
and they became presbyterian they
emigrated from from Northern Ireland and
they emigrated from Scotland in part
because those are pretty inhospitable
places and there was a much greater
opportunity in the colonies like your
book points out by the time of the
American Revolution the Presbyterians
were the second largest religious group
in the United States while in the
colonies the American Revolution was
actually called by some other people at
that time that Presbyterian revolution
because they threw themselves into it as
opposed to some of the other religious
groups that weren't so weren't so into
it the American Revolution was not quite
as popular as because people make it out
to her to be the the Presbyterians got a
major role in that your book talks about
a few other things that we want to point
out as well so you've got these you've
got these Presbyterians emigrating to
the United States and you can tell like
like I was looking at all this stuff
that there's a key aspect or structure
you know the presbytery
you know they keep order they keep
discipline within the church everything
is supposed to be drawn from the Bible
if you're going to sing anything better
be a biblical canticle or even better a
song
now when you say this term order and you
think about religion you think about a
lot of rules right and what do you think
about more the head or the heart when it
comes to that sort of stuff how do you
know the right order of things you just
kind of feel your way to it or there's
something to memorize think about look
about your student conduct oh yeah do
you get into an argument with a
professor can you just say I thought I
was doing the
thing well that left like it's probably
not now if you actually look at it and
you read it and you think about it now
you're on firmer ground some of your
professors may not actually know what
the code says order can be can get kind
of stifling though sometimes some of you
may have had experiences of this when
you were growing up if you want
religious community where you felt like
it was just a lot of rules and doing
this at the right time and doing that at
the right time but your heart wasn't in
it
and so your book talks about something
else that occurs and this produces some
breaks within a Presbyterian talk about
they call the Great Awakening yeah this
was a sort of resurgence in religious
fervor in the United States that played
an important role not only for religion
but also for politics for culture for
literary works some of the other people
that we're going to look at later on
we're going to talk more about this so
don't forget this term the the
Presbyterians that would be most closely
associated is Great Awakening where
these guys tenets and your book talks
about demonstrating this law college now
the Presbyterians in general we're very
focused on things being orderly in
church having ministers who were
hopefully you know certainly university
trained college trained seminary trained
yeah this long college is doing
something a bit different lately your
book says tenant who wrote this this
tract as I mentioned it in your book
about the dangers of but yeah the danger
of an unconverted ministry he was
focused on the heart
the emotions or as they call them back
down the affections whenever you see
this from religious factions you should
think about the emotions because that's
what they were referring to and he
developed a new way of preaching at
least for Presbyterians other people
were doing this as well rather than just
taking a scripture passage and saying
here's what it means and here's you know
the evidence for the app and here's how
to apply it to your life he was focused
on getting people to feel differently
you know you can think about an academic
lecture or old school sermon as trying
to produce a conversion in your life
right so after we have this little
session in class and just some Q&A with
you
and sort of lay things out hopefully
some of the material that you've read is
a little bit more consolidated you had
those your experience with college
classes I think my lectures still have
some usefulness at all does it affect
your hurt do you find yourself you know
on fire and saying wow this is really
changing me I see things with a whole
new way probably not not an academic
experience it'll be strange if somebody
actually jumped up and say hallelujah it
all makes sense now that would be kind
of weird I don't expect that they kept
moving money classes if you want to
freak me out at some point I suppose one
of you could do that at some time I'm
not even sure what I would make of it no
no II haven't thank thank goodness
because honest to god I don't know what
I would do but that gives you an idea of
how different that is now this guy was
interested in producing conversion of
the heart that's what he was talking
about the dangers of a fun converted
ministry his idea was that the people
who are actually doing the preaching
themselves should have he had an
emotional conversion experience they
should have come to you know meet Jesus
you know not just face to face but hurt
to heart that that should be evident in
the way
they they preach otherwise they're not
going to be able to do a very good job
and they're not going to be able to
produce that for their their their
congregation of the participants in that
so this started a big you know rift
within the Presbyterian ranks this
points to kind of tension that
constantly goes on the order let's call
it the tension between order and
affection which one are you going to
favor which one are you going to focus
on what are some of the dangers of too
much of the other one that's not
necessarily think about something
religious think about clubs that you
belong to other activities that you've
been involved in or think about academic
you know academic classes and lectures
what's the danger petting just just
order just an emphasis on that what
happens yeah yeah this is this is a big
problem for a lot of things in in
academics and then after a while you
start saying why the hell am i doing
this you know just for just for the gray
just for the credit this is really what
would be the word does is really terms
of the B or e yeah
what happens if all you got is
touchy-feely now tell me how you feel
kind of stopped have you have you got
any classes like that I am terrible I'd
almost rather have a boring lecture than
that what are some of the dangers of too
much of a focus on motion yeah
yeah you might not want to share how
you're feeling you might not want other
people in that business so to speak and
you might know I don't know what other
people are feeling
- yeah could it keep you from from doing
what you need to do if all you have is a
sort of on a structured emotional patent
because you a lot of passion to do this
but then you're sure like running around
you know the Presbyterians were trying
to deal with an age-old problem how do
you bring the two of these together yeah
for the most part they came down usually
as I a border matter of fact if you go
to a Presbyterian Church you will meet
people who talk in terms of the heart
but you'll also see for the most part a
lot of emphasis still on discipline on
structure on order and that as being
part of their tradition they also talk
about higher education in here now that
that's starting to become more and more
of an important thing as we go on
through these other chapters a lot of
Presbyterians were in New Jersey what's
what's up I'm in the school in New
Jersey
yeah no your book talks about that
starting out as the College of New
Jersey then you don't change this thing
a lot of colleges have changed their
name over time that started out as a
Presbyterian establishment just like
Harvard started out as the Puritan
school and the job was to Train
ministers and then to train other people
as well over time you know if you go to
Princeton now do you think you see a lot
of Presbyterian influenced problem right
anymore
at Harvard but that was the origin of a
lot of our important early educational
institutions had had religious roots now
your book talks about some of the main
churches involved in the Presbyterian
Church but I'm gonna skip over that and
we'll talk about that in later chapters
absolutely what I will get some of the
some of the other reform so the
Reformation starts in Germany and then
it spreads all over the place yeah when
we talk about the reformed in the
Reformation we're talking about people
who are influenced by Calvin the part of
his movement so we're talking about
Switzerland we're talking about Germany
we're talking about the Netherlands or
Holland and we're talking about France
and then we're talking about other
places like like Hungary is a business
spread most of those nationalities they
have their own national Presbyterian on
presidency Reformed churches well touch
with the Welsh as well they haven't got
more of us disappearing quite a few of
them ended up here in the United States
getting absorbed into Presbyterian
churches the one group that was
successful in maintaining its own ethnic
identity was the Dutch and whoopee
actually talks about this this slogan if
you're not Dutch you're not much that
they say up in Michigan where there are
a lot of Dutch Reformed Calvin College
ISM is in that area there's quite a few
here still in New York the county that I
used to live right next door to in
Indiana also has a very high proportion
of Jasper County has a very high
proportion of the the dr. forum and
that's where I actually heard the
expression
you're not touching that much they tend
to be kind of you know closed off but
it's partly because they're they have a
religious identity as well as an ethnic
identity they're they're not speaking
Dutch by the way they're speaking
English but you could go to areas like
that you'll find a lot of Dutch names
like when salir you know I have a hard
time pronouncing these Dutch names
student mentor now the Dutch Reformed
like your book talks about ended up
splitting into a couple different
churches as well yeah I give you some
some information about that in other
lessons why did the Dutch retain their
identity do you think that doesn't an
interesting puzzle why didn't why did
the French disappear into the Dutch
Church isn't into American Presbyterian
churches look a Dutch not any ideas what
does it tell you
but it's interesting sometimes to
speculate about it this is something
scholars actually are kind of divided
about we know that it didn't happen
probate the roots of the why asking a
philosophical question is much more
difficult with the German churches they
disappeared in part because in Germany
these churches got rolled into each
other the ones that spoke English it was
very easy for them to disappear into
Presbyterian denominations or into
Congregationalist denominations Dutch is
significantly different you might then
say well Wyatt why did the French well
little more Dutch then there were French
in most of these areas so that you can
ask the French reformed well often would
just join Dutch churches and take
which identity benefits not a full
answer to the question but it's worth
considering